let me tell you a story about my boyfriend and this broken lamp
a little backstory
I have four children
and I love crows
I got a crow tattoo
I have a bunny tattoo
like I just love birds and animals and outdoors and all that
and so when I saw this lamp on the TikTok shop
I was like oh
my god I would not shut up about it
pretty sure I bought it with my own actual money
I was like no
I love this fucking lamp
I'm so excited to get this fucking lip
I wouldn't shut up about the fucking lamp
and then I got the lamp
and I was so excited when I got the fucking lamp
I set it up on my
my kitchen table
and I was like
look at how cool it is
because the thing is
the crow is holding the electrical cord
holding the light bulb up for you to see in its mouth
and it just like
looks really cool
and it's like a really good um
way to kinda not have the cord be a mess
like the cord is a part of the art
so it's not I don't know
I just love the lamp
and I would not shut up about the lamp
he was here when it broke and saw my face
was like ah I
I mean I had had the lamp for like
an hour before it broke
he bought me another one
it's the coolest fucking lamp
this is the crow
he just knew how excited I was about the fucking lamp
he was like not on my watch
god damn it I'll get you another fucking lamp
okay but look
the crow holds
shut up
see isn't that cool
a really cool lamp
like he's bringing you the light
I don't know I just fucking love it
and I know don't let it fall